I'm in Crystal Palace Park in South
London and there are dinosaurs models of
dinosaurs anyway and inaccurate models
at that but that's because they're more
than 150 years old these were the first
ever life-size models of extinct
creatures built for the gardens of the
enormous Crystal Palace that used to
stand on top of a hill over there they
were made by the wonderfully named
Benjamin Waterhouse Hawkins we now know
that they are utterly wrong in many
significant ways but at the time they
were a marvel mock at what once walked
the earth now in England there is a list
of buildings that have special
protection under the law buildings on
that list are called listed buildings
because they're on the list of buildings
and this country is full of them
historic England the not-quite
government organization that manages the
list says there's about half a million
buildings on it
most of those are only grade 2 listed
which means they've got to be kept
mostly intact and any changes need a
really good reason behind them but more
than 10,000 places are grade 1 listed
which means they must be preserved
pretty much anything that was built more
than 200 years ago and it's still
standing is on the list but there are
some more modern things - including
these dinosaurs yep
grade 1 listed dinosaurs can't be
changed moved or demolished have to be
kept in good condition and they can't be
updated to reflect what modern
paleontologists now know because that
would involve changing them and
destroying not a dinosaur display but a
display about what we once thought
dinosaurs looked like something that's
notable not because of what it
represents in itself but because of the
history in the sculptures these
dinosaurs must by law remain inaccurate
because the story they tell isn't about
prehistoric times it's about science
just 150 years ago I've done a video
with minute earth about no island the
busiest place that doesn't exist you can
go check it out on their Channel